Christopher columbus has become a
controversial historical figure.
I claims for centuries as
the discovery of America.
He wasn't.
He has gains notoriety for the
decimation of the native peoples that he
encountered obsessed with obtaining goals,
slaves in order to pay off debt and
impress the king and queen of Spain.
He ended up as an outcast on ones that
in the place that he discovered and sent
back to Spain in disgrace.
In this week's biographics,
we're looking at the uncomfortable
truth about Christopher Columbus.
There is no agreed upon date as to when
Christopher Columbus entered into the
weld.
Some historians put the
date as early as 1436,
but others claim that
it was as late as 1455.
The majority agree though that he was
born sometime between August the 25th and
October 31st in 14,
51.
The place of his birth,
though.
That's something we do know for certain.
It's the Italian coastal city of genuine.
Christopher was the
oldest of five children,
born to Susanna Fontana,
Rossa and Dominica Colombo.
The name Columbus is an English
derivation of the Italian Colombo.
Dominica was a weaver and an innkeeper,
but he was also a keen seafarer and his
love of the ocean would soon transfer to
his oldest son as early as age 10,
Christopher ranged up and down the
genuine harbor in borrowed single man
sailboats and dreams of venturing
out into the vast expanse beyond.
We know very little about
Christopher's early life,
but we do know that his father was able
to provide a modest yet comfortable
living for the family and that he was a
kindly involved man who brought his sons
up with strong biblical morals.
We don't even know if young
Christopher went to school.
It was recorded that he
was a great intellect,
this listen education,
and so he may have been illiterate when
he left home at around the age of 20.
Still,
he overcame his lack of formal education
by teaching himself many valuable
skills including matt making functional
mathematics and the range of languages
including Spanish,
Latin,
and Portuguese.
By the time he sailed to the Americas,
he had also learned to read and to write.
Okay.
It is generally agreed that Columbus
first went to see at the age of 14,
he began his Maritime Korea as a messenger
and worked his way up to the position
of common sailor for the next six years.
He works in a variety of ships
that plying the European oceans.
A legend has emerged at the age of
21 columbus tried his hand at piracy.
He was in the employee of Duke Renea.
I've owned Jew who had appointed the young
man to capture a warship in the Tunis
harbor in North Africa on
roots of the men with Columbus,
got Tim Ids and persuaded him to
send him back to France and gathered
reinforcements.
The story goes that during the night,
Columbus played a trick on his men by
altering the ship's compass so that they
sailed south instead of north.
When they broke,
they were within sight of the target.
Washington's Columbus managed to
Ronnie as men for a successful attack.
Many scholars dismissed the accounts due
to the fact that Columbus was only 21,
which seems far too young
to be given such a command.
There's more certainty regarding a
voyage that he took two years later.
The destination was the Greek
islands of kiosks in the Aegean Sea.
He ends the rest of the crew.
Spent a year on the islands in 1476 at
the age of 25 Columbus first ventured
beyond the realms of the Mediterranean
and into the wider oceans beyond.
He was part of a fleet of five ships,
bound for Lisbon in Portugal on route
to the fleet was attacked by a Franco
Portuguese war fleet.
In the ensuing battleships
from both sides,
went down with hundreds of men.
Drowning Columbus was on the big hello,
which was struck and
sunk by a French worship.
It was only a stroke of fortune that
ended up saving Christopher's life diving
into the sea.
He managed to clean to a
floating or and used it as a boy.
He's against the Portuguese shore
at lag Os some six miles away.
Luckily the people of Lagos took him in
and he's got him back to good health.
He managed to make his way from the to
Lisbon where he joins up with a large
colony of January.
His ship builders,
merchants,
in 1477,
he joined a voyage to Iceland,
which he described as much
beyond the limit of the West.
We're to Lisbon.
He learns much of the inner
workings of the seafaring trait.
This port city was the center of
seafaring voyage and discovery.
It was the place where stories of what
lay beyond we're told and schemes of
exploration.
Expound it.
During this time,
Columbus undertook the study of astronomy,
geography,
and celestial navigation.
In 1478,
he set off for the three
key Atlantic Archipelagos.
The first islands greet
visitors were the Azores,
800 miles west of Portugal.
The other two were the Madeira
archipelago and the Canary Islands.
During these voyages,
Columbus gained valuable experience on
the open seat on his return to Lisbon,
Christopher mets,
and fell in love with a 25 year old
woman by the name of Phillipa Munez.
Despite being of noble birth and with
family connections to the Portuguese
course,
Philipa does not come
from a wealthy family.
When the two were married just a few
months after the courtship began,
her father had no dowery to offer.
The newlyweds settled in the town of
Porto Santo and the Madeira Islands where
Felipe,
his father had previously
done the governor in 1480.
A son was born and his name was diego.
Soon after giving birth though died.
The details surrounding
her demise are unclear,
but most historians believe
that the course was tuberculosis
by the age of 30.
Christopher Columbus had developed a
great deal of skill and experience as an
ocean voyage.
He had traveled as far as Iceland to
the northern Ghana to the west still.
He was fascinated with what lay further
out the area beyond the horizon was
known as the Green Sea of darkness,
and that was much speculation about
what could be found that Columbus was
convinced the by sailing west,
he would eventually end up in Asia.
This was a novel idea and
before you could test it out,
he needed to gain academic support for
his belief along with his brother bottle,
a mayor.
He spends months pouring
over geographical maps,
astronomical with books
and other related works.
When you found anything that
supported his hypothesis,
he underlined this and
scribbled it into his notepad.
Columbus.
This study led to three key assumptions
upon which he funded his belief.
Firstly,
there was only one ocean,
the Atlantic,
and he believed it to be narrowed.
His second seconds belief was that the
world was relatively small and that Asia
was much closer to Europe than
it actually ended up being.
His final assumption was that there was
no large landmass between Europe and
Asia.
In hindsight,
we know that Columbus was
guilty of selective research.
Anything that didn't support his
hypothesis was rejected outright.
He gains much support from the writings
of Marco Polo and first century
cartographer Marianas of tie.
This convinced him that if he sailed u,
s t would reach Asia
in less than 3000 miles
with the scientific backing,
but he needed Columbus now set out
to find a backup for his plans,
voyage of discovery more
than mere financial support.
He was after a Royal Baca who could go
under him the prestige and status that he
would earn by such a perilous
journey in his own words.
He wanted to be in Zionsville to call
myself dawn and should be high admiral of
the ocean,
sea,
and device.
Ryan,
governor in perpetuity of all the islands
and the mainland and I discover and
gain all the termites thereafter be
discovered and gains in the ocean sea,
and so that's my eldest son should
succeed me and his as then forth from
generation to generation forever
and ever in return for such honors,
Columbus would bestow the riches of Asia.
Upon these sponsoring sovereign tobacco
is course he quoted from the journals of
Marco Polo about the riches of the orients
having lived in Portugal for the past
eight years.
It was only natural that his first
request was made to that country's king,
but despite his persuasiveness,
Columbus is proposal,
it was rejected.
The king viewed this unproved.
Sander is being vain and conceited
and rather parental bragging.
The fact that in addition to the owners,
Columbus also demanded one 10th of all
income derived did not help his course.
Even beyond all that,
the vast majority of the king's advisors
believed that the plans are reached.
The Orient by sailing west was nothing
more than a fool's errands with a round
rejection from his adopted country.
Columbus set his sights on the king of
Spain by now the would be adventure.
I was 34 years of age,
penniless,
widowed,
and with a young son to care for
arriving in these Spanish port town of
panelists with five-year-old Diego,
and so he first attempt to find food
lodging and a place for the ato to stay as
his father made his approach to the king,
Columbus made his way to a Franciscan
monastery overlooking the pleaded poverty
for the next five months.
This monastery would be as base
then towards the end of 1945,
he made his way to court data to seek an
audience with King Ferdinand and Queen
Isabella.
He had to wait for the to return
from Madrid and during this time,
that's a young woman named
Beatrice on request to Herana.
She began his mistress giving
birth to his second son,
Ferdinand's on August the 15th,
14,
88.
The audience before the King and
Queen was granted on May the first 14,
86.
Columbus and Isabella develops and
immediate bonds being of the same age and
clearly they were like minded still.
The monarchs turn the idea
over to an investigator,
Columbus would have to wait for five
and a half frustrating years to learn of
their final decision during that time.
He had returned to Lisbon in an attempt
to reopen negotiations with the king
there,
but all to no avail.
In the end of the Spanish
commission also rejected the plan,
their main reasons for doing so whether
the voyage to Asia would require an
absence of three years.
This was far too long with the available
technology and it's the belief that if
a ship did manage to get to
the other side of the world,
there was no way that it would be
able to get back the final decision.
However,
it was left to King
Ferdinand and Queen Isabella.
The king was happy to go along with the
commission's recommendation after all he
disliked Columbus on the personal level.
The queen,
however,
took pains to reassure Columbus that he
would be able to resubmit his plan in
the future.
The Spanish struggle against the most
at this point had been going on for 700
years and it was nearly at a conclusion
when this was decided the queen and told
him he would get a better reception.
On January the second 14,
92,
the Morrish city of Granada
fell to the Spanish.
Shortly thereafter,
the Royal Minister of the budget,
he was friendly with Columbus and trusted
about mcqueen to show favor to the
mariners scheme.
She relented in Columbus,
who was down on his way back to
Cordova or on the back of a mule,
was intercepted and rushed to the
royal palace to receive the good news.
After waiting for five years,
it took Columbus just 10 weeks to gather
together the three ships crew and the
supplies that he needed.
His three ships,
they,
Nina pins are in Santa Maria,
were skillfully built and according to
him were well suited for the task at
hands.
Columbus gathered a group of 19 men
to be split between the three ships.
The fleet left early
morning on August the third,
14,
92.
The first stop was the Canary
Islands thousand miles to the south.
Then the ships were refitted
and resupplied before
heading out into the Green
Sea of darkness.
The ship's made good progress,
thanks to strong easterly
winds off to some days.
They entered into an area
known as the Saragossa Sea.
All around the waters
were filled with Gulf.
We're to thick green plants that are
floated on the surface at the same time as
this was happening,
the wind's died down to almost nothing.
After three weeks at sea,
the cre begins aside,
land nesting birds.
Still.
There was no citing of lands.
As the weeks passed,
with no indications of Terra Firma,
the creek became increasingly
agitated onboard the Santa Maria.
They were using close to musiny.
We things coming to a boiling point is
Columbus made an ultimate declaration on
October the 10th.
If land was not cited in three days,
he promised that he would
turn back two days later.
The long awaited word came
at 2:00 AM on the twelfth,
the cry of Tara,
Tara resounded from ship to ship.
Ninety pairs of eyes strained to see
the islands that was six miles in the
distance.
Columbus promised that the first man
to site land would receive a yearly
pension,
have a thousand married aviators
for the rest of his life.
Yes.
That's and to say the name is
Rodrigo ever received this reward.
Columbus claims do have seen a line to
the evening before and gave himself the
reward that come across in Ireland,
situated in the middle of the Caribbean.
Seed it was populated by are like Indians.
These were a friendly people and some
of them swung out to meet the new
comments.
These people lived in village communes
and to develops an agricultural economy.
They have no iron implements,
but Columbus was quick to notice that
they wore tiny pieces of goals in memory
is Columbus,
was determined to get to the
source of the Arawaks gold.
He at some of the natives of borders
ships and then took them as prisoners.
He demanded that they guide into the
place why the gold was located not having
success in sales to modern day Cuba,
and then to Hispaniola it was that,
that his visions of a vast gold empire.
Well,
rekindles,
when a local chief presented
him with a gold mask,
Columbus and his men build a
force on the island of Hispaniola.
Naming is another dad.
Christmas.
He left 39 men that with
strict orders to find the gold.
He then took more prisoners and began
for the return journey to Spain before
leaving his men killed two natives who
refuse to trade as many bows and arrows
as they demand is on the return.
Jenny,
some of the prisoners died
from exposure to cold weather.
What is the return to Spain?
Columbus made extravagant claims
about what he had encountered.
He stated that he had reached Asia
when in fact he had landed on Cuba.
He also spoke of rivers flowing with
golden's and abundance of spices.
He promised that with a little more
financial help from the king and Queen,
you could go back and pick up as much
gold as they needed and as many slaves as
they need it to.
The king and queen were
suitably and damage.
The second voyage was made up of
17 ships in more than 1,200 men.
Whereas the first trip had
been focused on reaching Asia.
Now the objective was twofold,
slaves and gold from islands,
islands.
They raged taking prisoners and demanding
that they be led to the goals as word
spreads of the impending danger.
Villages were evacuated and the sailors
who had been left at Nafa dabs were
executed with no goal to be found.
Columbus embarked upon
a massive slave drive,
$1,500,
proac men,
women and children with thrown into pens
and from them 500 of the best specimens
were chosen to be taken to Spain.
200 of these died on the way back with
the remainder being sold at auction.
Still Columbus was desperate to get
his hands on the goals in Haiti.
He ordered that every person aged 14 or
over was to collect a minimum quota of
goals every three months.
Those that succeeded were
given a capa necklace to app.
Anyone without the nexus
would have to hand cut off.
The reality was though there was hardly
any gold to be hands apart from small
amounts that can be found in streams.
The results of Columbus as gold
obsession was that in two years,
the black population was cut in half
with a hundred and 25,000 people being
murdered,
starve to death,
or committing suicide.
Columbus established his
base on Hispaniola and named
himself governor of the
islands.
The situation quickly devolved into chaos,
though most of the Europeans
on the islands were seconds.
Many of them were ex convicts.
They occupied themselves by raping the
native women and terrorizing the men and
children.
Looting was rampant and the quantity of
goals gathered was pitiful compared to
what Columbus promised.
In October of $14,
95,
a royal inspector arrived on Hispaniola
in the wake of worrying reports that had
reached the Spanish court.
The inspector soon gathered plenty
of evidence to indicate Columbus,
giving him no choice but to return to
Spain in order to defend himself before
the king and queen
setting sail on the Nina,
the 45 year old Columbus
arrived back in Portugal.
On June the 11th,
14,
46.
He clothed himself in a fry's robe as
a sign of Penitence and set out to meet
the solver writtens that Vegas,
which was some 500 miles from his
landing port or meeting the King Queen.
He immediately reassured them there
was still plenty of gold to be hats.
He also tried to convince them that
he had reached the Malay Peninsula of
Southeast Asia as a final enticements.
He told them on x that he was convinced
that there was a whole new continent
lying just to the south of the
islands that he had landed on.
To his surprise and great pleasure.
The king and queen were willing
to overlook the bad reports.
Dad received further.
They agreed to finance another voyage
specifically to confirm the existence of
this new continents.
However,
Columbus would have to wait a further
two years before adventuring again.
This time the sufferns insisted that
he take with him colonists rather than
soldiers.
The third voyage therefore
included 30 women,
50 farmers,
20 mechanics,
and 10 gardeners along with 30 sailors.
The fleet consisted of six ships,
which Columbus splits into
two separate commands.
The first three ships had to Hispaniola
with suppliers for the colony that was
located,
that the reigning ships made onfi
discovery fleet with Columbus at the helm.
They took a southerly routes to the
indies and such have any lands lying south
of the Antilles.
Throughout this voyage,
Columbus suffered from terrible pains,
gout,
as well as fever.
Land was first sighted
on July the 31st 14,
98,
and the fleet soon made in
Trinidad for the next two weeks.
They explored the area between Trinidad
and the South American mainland sailing
further west,
they sold lands again,
and it was at this point the Columbus
declared they had found the new continent
having achieved his objective.
Columbus set the fleet North Hispaniola.
When he arrived,
he found place in the state of rebellion.
While he was gone,
many of his men had died
mainly from starvation.
While those who survived were disgusted
at the harsh treatments that had been
subjected to under the nominal
rulership of Columbus's.
Brother Bartholomew Bartholomew was
the acting governor while Columbus,
who's away.
The rebels were led by a man named Roden
gathering both standards and natives to
his cause.
He set about the process of
overthrowing the franchise governments.
This Columbus had established after a
period of fierce fighting the exhausted
and physically ill,
columbus and treated with Roldan for
peace terms Columbus gave in to all of
Roland's demands,
including appointing him as mayor in
giving land grants to every standard who
wished to stay on the islands
with this humiliating defeat.
Columbus is only designed now,
was to leave.
Meanwhile,
news of the latest rebellion
had made his way to Spain.
The king had sent a man by the
name of Francisco Dibaba dealer.
They seven of the crown and a night.
His mission was to sort
the entire situation out.
He arrived in Hispaniola to discover
that a mass execution of the rebels was
underway just playing his rod loaders.
You put a halt to the proceedings in town,
Columbus,
and just to your brothers
thrown into ions.
The three brothers were
shipped back to Spain.
When the people there saw the greater
columbus in chains after the ship darker,
they became angry.
Hearing of this popular reaction,
the king ordered that they'd be freed.
Columbus has reunion with the king and
Queen was an emotionally charged a fap.
He threw himself at the queen's feats
and through solves Kista hands and feets.
He pleaded innocent saying this,
any wrongs he had committed,
whether the result of
ignorance and not wickedness.
This O'Brien's took pity on him and
his promise to restore his wealth and
titles.
The king,
however,
was convinced that while
he may be superior at see,
Columbus was no governor of men on lance
still his skills as a voyager where an
asset that could be further
utilized and as a result,
Ferdinand authorized a fourth voyage to
the West indies in the hopes of finding
a direct route to Asia.
However,
he was ordered to stay
well away from Hispaniola.
This time it was strictly
a voyage of discovery.
Columbus set forth on this final voyage
on May the nine slash 15 slash two is
fleet reached the West indies.
In 21 days,
two weeks later,
his three ships encountered a terrible
storm which they managed to see through
with no loss of life.
The fleet eventually reached
the offshore islands of Banana,
a few miles from Honduras,
from them,
they encountered terrible see
conditions for 38 straight days,
which tested the men
to the absolute limits.
Finally,
they found their way to
the Panamanian coastline.
Here they were heartened
to find goals in abundance.
They spend the next several months
traveling up and down the coast,
gathering gold,
and then they headed back for Hispaniola,
but the weather beaten and he's in ships.
They never reached Hispaniola
with the ship's taking on water.
They barely limps into Jamaica.
The ships went now,
useless in the party,
remained stranded for only a year.
I need to be rescued.
When two ships arrived from Santa Domingo,
Columbus and his men were taken to
Hispaniola to recover from that ordeal,
but the former governor
knew that he was not there.
As soon as he could manage it,
he found a passage on a ship bound for
Spain and arrived back on November the
seventh,
15.
Oh,
four.
Columbus returned to Spain,
sick,
broken,
and distance.
He was so ill that he could
hardly stand on his own power.
However,
he still had the stamina to demands an
accounting of as accumulated possessions,
your agreements that he had made years
ago with Ferdinand and Isabella for a
10th of all bouncy.
I'd made him a rich man
and now sort the claimants.
As a result,
gold was shipped to him and he
was given land in Hispaniola.
Got The wealth.
It came too late for Columbus
to enjoy it in May of 15.
Oh,
six is bad.
Health deteriorated.
Fatally.
He became bedridden and on May the 19th,
the priest was called to
administer the last rites.
He died the next day.
Moments after whispering in your hands,
Lord,
I command my spirit.
It was 54 years of age,
so I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel
for brand new biographies every Monday
and every Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel
that's called today.
I found out it's sort of like biographics,
but way more broad on that channel.
We get deep into all of the details
on all sorts of interesting stuff.
Check it out through the
link on the screen now,
but if you look for something
else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the
archives or two that are found out video
over there on the rice and as always,
thank you for watching.